this is my whole world my nurse my mom
my sickness I'm 18 and I've never been
outside everyday was exactly the same
until Ollie oh good you want house
arrest I haven't seen you outside once
since we got here
no I'm sick my body can't fight bacteria
or infections if I left the house I
would die where would you go if you
could the ocean station that's three
miles from here I've never seen it wish
I could meet you in person he sounds
wonderful if you can't
I'm right here here here I understand
you're nervous yeah I'm nervous or more
see really different I thought you're
going to be sexier right there mom
I found this new part of myself and I
met ollie if I don't go I won't really
know what it's like to be alive
go back inside no the only way they'll
know so we shouldn't push our luck but
it was like that maybe with that he was
wrong it was easier where I knew who are
supposed to be at the doorway that I'm
willing to sacrifice everything just to
live one perfect day
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you